do these new claims over lockdown signal
an end to your political career
what
about
Mr Johnson what are these what's
happening what are the WhatsApp messages
tell us about your behavior during
lockdown
do they further impune your integrity
sir
is your political career over Mr Johnson
Mr Johnson do these lockdown claims
finish your political career
so you're being paid a lot of money on a
speaking engagement in the United States
people in the UK might want to hear you
speak on a matter that matters to them
I'm gonna be a customer so please stop
by
Mr Johnson will you be Mr Johnson will
you be further embarrassed by your
WhatsApp messages during lockdown
it will be further impure your integrity
sir
Mr Johnson
what did your constituents have to gain
from your meeting with Donald Trump
Mr Johnson you have formed in terms of
breaking the law on Covert have you
broken it again
no and I I've been here to talk about
Ukraine that's what I've been doing and
why wouldn't you talk about covert
you've been accused of Breaking the Law
at Checkers and at Downing Street did
you no but uh you're like
um it's there if it's proved that you
did are you finished as a politician
the answer is that
um
as I said before there was absolutely no
uh
rule breaking and you know
what proof do you have of that well look
you know those who want to make
allegations should make allegations and
so far nobody has and you're my honest
view I think this whole thing is
completely nonsensical and look I've got
to check in for a flight now this whole
thing is a load of absolute nonsense
um
I think he was absurd that it was
decided to pass entries in my diary to
the uh
police
what do these entries say what do these
entries say they merely record events in
my uh in my day meeting friends at
Checkers when you shouldn't have been
absolutely not
absolutely not and that will be
demonstrated what did they demonstrate
and I've got nothing more to say
I'm asking you very politely to back up
please
thank you
I'm gonna ask that you do not impede us
okay
so I'm asking us we want it we won't
yeah do you understand yeah okay thank
you I appreciate that
this hopefully is a load of nonsense
from beginning to end and we've made
that clear in the statements that I've
issued
um I think that it's ridiculous that
elements in my diary should be
cherry-picked and handed over to
the police to the Privileges committee
uh without even anybody having the the
basic common sense
to ask me what these entries referred to
what do they refer to there is
absolutely nothing in those entries that
constitutes uh rule breaking during
covid restrictions okay mingling with
friends at Checkers that is absolutely
not what those diary entries show that
is not what those diary entries show and
the whole thing is totally nonsensical
who is trying to stitch you up Mr
Johnson who well who do you think is
trying to set you up
who do you think is trying to set you up
yeah and don't just let's let's go let's
go
who is trying to set you up Sir is it
Richie sunai look I think
where are you come on where are you yeah
I've asked you it's okay he's from Sky
News he's from Sky News he's being he's
entitled to ask me questions and I'm
going to tell you I just think it's
totally nonsense School
and
um bizarre that
there are tens of thousands of entries
in the the prime minister of Derry I've
never seen these things before looking
like look through it
um none of them constitute a breach of
the rules during during covid during
that and they weren't during lockdown
they were doing other periods of the of
the restrictions none of them
constituted reach of the rules none of
them involve uh socializing it is total
nonsense and
um I find it extraordinary absolutely
extraordinary that these things are
handed over
by I don't know quite what Authority the
the cabinet office or whoever to the
Privileges committee and to the police
without any attempt to establish what
these things actually mean or what they
refer to and with me
and I can assure you that I can assure
the public that they're all incompletely
innocent and within the rules and you
know you talk about a stitch up you talk
about you you just you you just said you
said originally you're being staged up
by whom Richie
not I mean somebody's somebody's well
let's talk about Skip for reasons for
reasons that
um
somebody somewhere thinks it's sensible
to do this I don't take care of us let's
talk of a skip fire in the Tory party
would you encourage that and do you see
that as a potential comeback for you
oh that's former prime minister Boris
Johnson there speaking to our U.S
correspondent James Matthews returning
from a visit to the United States in
which he said it's absurd that um
that they passed
details from his uh diary entries to the
police
um the whole thing is a load of nonsense
from beginning to end and nothing that
he did constitutes rule breaking so that
exclusive with our U.S correspondent
James Matthews there who we hope to
speak to once we return from our break
so that was